foreign
[Music]
daily cancellation may be accused of
being a bit unfocused I would blame it
on ADHD but I've already canceled ADHD
multiple times during the same segment
the problem is that I wanted to dedicate
the cancellation to the worst examples
of democrat cringe heading into election
day but the cringe just kept piling up
one on top of another creating a sort of
leaning tower of cringe a mountain you
might even say a cringe volcano spewing
hot liquid cringe all over the all over
the ground sending particles of cringe
into the air threatening to blot out the
Sun and send us all into an eternal
winter so all I can do is is go through
this bit by bit now I have no
overarching eloquent point to make but
then again if you wanted eloquent points
you wouldn't be watching the show to
begin with and so we just have to Dive
Right In with this get out the vote
music video produced by a leftist pack
called Midas Touch you may recall from
Greek mythology that King Midas turned
everything he touched into gold
it's up to you whether this qualifies
but here it is
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
despicable and cynical yeah
but we're coming up on an important
deadline it's time
[Music]
you know it's actually kind of catchy I
mean it's it's not good but like by the
standards of this sort of thing
I don't know it's it's like an early
2000s era Vanessa Carlton without the
vocal range of the songwriting ability
morphed with Rebecca Black
which which still is slightly better
than what you would expect but still not
great
in summary democracy was a mistake
there's a reason to identify as a
Theocratic fascist and when I finally
rise to power and take my rightful
Throne my very first decree will be that
all the get out the vote songs are
banned which I suppose will be somewhat
redundant because voting will also be
banned for the good of the country but
that's not the only form of musical
cringe taking us into election day in
fact somehow
it gets worse in the last week signaling
the
um ultimate form of desperation various
Democrat candidates have started
recording dancing Tick-Tock videos
now this shouldn't be
as all that bad you might think because
for all their faults Democrats tend to
be better dancers than Republicans I
have no data or research to back that up
it just seems intuitively true and yet
it's the worst dancers in the Democrat
Party who are dancing their way into the
midterms here's a very brief compilation
so I'm looking for a yellow bone long
hair star
star
I'm a Savage yeah
[Music]
what was happening
hips come get in my car
Gretchen Whitmer probably fared the best
of that group I would say though she
still looks like your drunk aunt at the
wedding reception unsurprisingly uh when
Beto O'Rourke dances he has the look of
a man holding in a fart perhaps we
should call that dance move the
swallwell I don't know then there was
Tim Ryan of Ohio who dances like uh a
little bit like a toddler at a Wiggles
concert
and I know I promised that I wouldn't
make any overarching points here but but
if I were to make one I would point out
that the tick tock of dances are a
symptom of the total lack of seriousness
and dignity among our political Elite
the countries always had political Elite
Right For Better or Worse usually For
Worse
but at least there used to be a certain
sense of decorum in that class at least
in front of the public
now they all share the same vices of the
political Elite of any other age except
we have to add that they're desperate
undignified you know the desperate
undignified cringe Factor has to be
added to the list now
speaking of which Tim Ryan makes a
second appearance in the cringe Roundup
with a video posted on Friday
um purporting to show off his skills at
the shooting range or lack thereof here
it is
[Music]
thank you
not bad for Democrat
s
not bad for a Democrat he says amazingly
however it actually is bad even for a
Democrat the bar is extremely low when
it comes to Democrats and Firearms after
all these are the people known to
confuse earplugs with rubber bullets yet
Tim Ryan has managed to get under a bar
that would be buried in the earth if it
was if it was set any lower
so let's just take a look at a freeze
frame to assess his form on this so he's
got his knees locked head down
leaning back like he's anticipating
recoil from like a 50 caliber machine
gun
I taught my nine-year-old daughter how
to shoot a BB gun and her form was
immediately better than this
in fact if she had formed this bat she'd
be grounded for a week for bringing
shame to our family and this is to say
nothing of the fact that he's standing
10 feet from the Target and his grouping
still looked like he was shooting blind
and drunk from like 500 yards away
keep in mind too that these are the best
angles and shots they could find for him
they probably had them out there at the
range for like several hours trying to
get 15 seconds worth of usable footage
and this is what they had to run with
that I mean I would have run the footage
right to the trash bin and moved on but
that's just me
it's somewhat confusing as to why they
even put this video out given how
incredibly embarrassing it is for Tim
Ryan but then you realize that they have
no respect for the voters they're
pandering to
the assumption is that blue collar
voters in Ohio will be just impressed
that he's shooting a gun and they'll
vote for him on that basis Alone look he
makes the gun go bang bang he's just
like us we should vote for him
that's the calculation they're expecting
which isn't surprising given that these
are the same people who think that you
just learned the word inflation three
months ago
what they don't understand is that gun
rights voters
don't need to see you shooting guns in
fact they'd rather not see you shoot
guns if you shoot like that
what they want to know is that you
respect their constitutional rights
that's what matters to them
but the Common Thread here is that
Democrats do not understand the voters
they're trying to Pander to much less do
they like them or respect them
and that's just another reason why
they're going to lose tomorrow and why
they are today canceled the day ahead of
time that'll do it for this portion of
the shows and move over to the members
block hope to see you there if not talk
to you tomorrow Godspeed
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]